قال البيت الابيض اليوم الاثنين عند
الرئيس جو بايدن عبر لرئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي عن مخاوفه بشان الوضع في
اسرائيل وان تل ابيب لم تعالج بعض القلق
الامريكي من التعديلات القضائيه وكانت
واشنطن قد اعربت عن قلقها البالغ من
احتمال تاثير تلك التطورات على استعداد
الجيش الاسرائيلي واكدت اهميه الحفاظ على
القيم الديمقراطيه في علاقات الجانبين
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي ابعاد ودلالات
واعراب واشنطن عن قلقها من الازمه
السياسيه في اسرائيل وتداعيتها المحتمله
على الاستعداد العسكري للجيش الاسرائيلي
وما فحوى الاتصالات الاخيره بين واشنطن
وتل ابيب وامكانيه ممارسه اداره بايدن
ضغوطا على نتنياهو وما خياراته الاخيره
التعامل مع الاداره الامريكيه ما هي
الانعكاسات المحتمله للمشهد السياسي في
اسرائيل على علاقات واشنطن بتل ابيب وعلى
مصالح الولايات المتحده وسياساتها في
المنطقه
[موسيقى]
بحسب منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في
البيت الابيض جوكر بي فان الاداره
الامريكيه تراقب عن كثب وبقلق بالغ
التطورات في اسرائيل وتحث قادتها على
التوصل الى تسويه كوربي اضافها ان قلقا
عميقا يساوي اداره الرئيس جو بايدن بشان
الاحداث في اسرائيل وان تل ابيب لم تعالج
بعد القلق الامريكي من التعديلات القضائيه
ووفقا لكربي ايضا فان رئيس بايدن ابدى
مخاوفه لرئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي مباشره
وان بايدن ليس قلقا من احتمال اندلاع حرب
اهليه في اسرائيل ولا يتوقع حدوثها وشدد
كوربي على ان الجانب الامريكي كان واضحا
مع الاسرائيليين حين حذرهم من ان مظاهر
القلق من التعديلات القضائيه في اسرائيل
ستطفو على السطح
المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي
كان قد قال ان الرئيس بايدن الذي كشفت
صحيفه يدعو تحررونوت عن ان نتنياهو ابلغه
نيته تجميده تعديلات القضائيه اكد
لنتنياهو ضروره بقاء القيم الديمقراطيه
سمه مميزه للعلاقه بين الولايات المتحده
واسرائيل واضاف المتحدث ان واشنطن تشعر
بقلق عميق اذا التطورات ومن تاثيرها
المحتمل على الاستعداد العسكري للجيش
الاسرائيلي
[موسيقى]
مناقشه الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من واشنطن
السفير بيجي كراولي المتحدث السابق باسم
الخارجيه الامريكيه ومن تل ابيب الدكتور
مردخاي كدار استاذه العلوم السياسيه
بجامعه والباحث في شؤون الشرق الاوسط
مرحبا بكما
على ماذا يؤشر هذا القلق الامريكي الكبير
مما يحصل في اسرائيل
اولا العلاقات بين الولايات المتحده
واستراليا علاقات وثيقه وهي تستند الى
ركيزه
الاستراتيجيه على سبيل المثال التعاون بين
اسرائيل
في محاوله
الحد من اتساع نفوذ ايران في المنطقه كما
ان للعلاقه بعد سياسي لان اسرائيل هي
نظاما
ديمقراطين فاعل وكما قال الرئيس بايدن في
عده محادثات مع بن جميل نتنياهو بان لو
هذه التغييرات القضائيه ستجعل من اسرائيل
اقل ديمقراطيه فهذا سيكون باعث قلق لدى
الوقت المتحده وعلى هذا الاساس حذر
نتنياهو من ان لا تذهب هذه التعديلات
بعيدا كيف تنوي تل ابيب معالجه هذا القلق
الامريكي الكبير
ما علاقه للترابيب في هذا السؤال العاصمه
الاسرائيليه هي القدس
اعطى هذا السؤال انا اسالك ارجوك ان تعيد
السؤال ساعيد السؤال يمكنني الاجابه على
هذا السؤال كيف تنوي حكومه بنيامين
نتنياهو معالجه هذا القلق الامريكي
ليس اي سبب للكلق الامريكي اسرائيل
ديمقراطيه وطيده
قويه
وما يدوره اليوم هو صراع بين قوتين بين
الكنيسه المنتخبه وبين السلطه القضائيه
التي استولت على بعض الامور في هذه الدوله
وعلى الجميع ان يجلسوا سويا
لياتوا بالصيغه التي يتمكن الجميل من
الاتفاق عليها هذا هو المشكله ولذلك لا
قلق لا لا خوف عليهم ولا هم يحزنون
ولكن العلاقه متوتره بين حكومه نتنياهو
والبيت الابيض وهذا واضح من التصريحات
سالتك هل معنيه حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو
بتبديد هذا القلق الامريكي مما يحصل في
اسرائيل داخليا
[موسيقى]
مختلفه من الناحيه النظريات قال ثقافيه
نفهم منك باقتضاب لو سمحت بان حكومه
نتنياهو لا تبالي لهذا القلق الامريكي على
ما يحصل في اسرائيل داخليا
هناك طرف معين حصل على الاغلبيه بالتالي
على الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان تتعامل
وتتقبل ما يريد هذا الجانب
هناك الكثير من اجاباته اولا اقول نعم هذا
سؤال سياسي اسرائيلي هذا صحيح والامر
متروك للقاده الاسرائيلين ان يحددوا كيف
يحكمون هذا بحد ذاته ليس امرا محددا
متروكا الولايات المتحده ان تحله ثانيا
وكما هو واضح من خلال الادله ان هناك
حكومه اسرائيليه منتخبه ولديك ردود فعل من
نسبه لا يستهانوا بها من الكيان السياسي
في اسرائيل سواء كان متعلق باسرائيل او
تركيا او اي بلد اخر عندما تكون هناك
احتجاجات بهذه الطبيعه وهذا الحجم فان
الولايات المتحده دائما تحذر اصدقائها بان
الحكومات ينبغي عليها ان تستجيب
لصعوبها وانت تتصرف بناء على رغبات شعوبها
وان مسائل مثل هذه ينبغي ان تحلى باشكال
سلميه وديمقراطيه ما تحذر امريكا اسرائيل
منه هو الطريقه التي سنحذر بها اي طرف اي
صديق اي دوله تمر بهذه الازمه السياسيه
لكن لا يمكن انكاره انك اذا ما اقدمت على
خطوات من شانها اضعاف وتقويض السلطه
القضائيه المستقله التي تقوم بمهام
المراقب على السلطه التنفيذيه فهذا هذه
ركيزه اساسيه لاي نظام ديمقراطي
المتحده سيكون لها مواقف وتعبر عن قلقها
ايا كان المكان في العالم الذي ان نتحدث
عنه اذا ما رات ان هناك نيمار نظاما
ديمقرا طيا يصير صوب الاستبداد بهذه
الطريقه المتحده وانت تذكر بانها حذرت
نتنياهو خلال
مشاورات تشكيل الحكومه من مخاطر توزير
شخصيات تعتبر متطرفه بانها يمكن ان تكون
عقبه امام عجله الحكومه الاسرائيليه هل ما
يحصل اليوم يثبت صوابيه نظره وتحذيرات
البيت الابيض لنتنياهو
نحن اولاد كبار نحن لسنا بحاجه لنصيحه من
اي كان
من الخدانه نحن لسنا اولاد
وطرق
ودروب اسرائيل معروفه لنا اكثر من كل من
يسكن في واشنطن ولذلك نحن كشعب يهودي
اسرائيلي ننتظر من الاخرين ان يحترموا
قرارنا
الديموقراطي وان يحترموا حكومتنا مهما
كانت تشكيلاتها ولذلك انا من حين اخر
استغرب من الهيمنه التي يتكلم البعض الينا
وكاننا لا نعرف يميننا من شمالنا ولذلك
انا اتوقع خاصه من الاصدقاء الامريكيين
ونحن نشارك الكثير من القيم معهم
ان يحترموا السياسه الاسرائيليه باننا
نعرف دروبنا اكثر من الاخرين طيب نشرك
معنا من الجليل السيد اليف صباغ الباحث
والكاتب المتخصص في شان الاسرائيلي سيد
صباغ ما التاثيرات المحتمله للازمه على
الاستعدادات العسكريه للجيش الاسرائيلي
والتي تقلق الجانب الامريكي بتقديرك
بدون اي شك الجانب الاسرائيلي والقوى
الليبراليه حتى وان كانت يمينيه في
اسرائيل قلقه جدا من ليس فقط من امكانيه
العسكريه المستقبليه وانما لم الاجرام
الذي حصل خلال العقود الماضيه
ويمكن ان يلاحق بموجبه الاف القاده
العسكريين والمخابرات وحتى سياسيين في
الوقت الحاضر هذه الجرائم تركبتها اسرائيل
خلال 76 عام لم تمت وبالتالي
والدعم عن اسرائيل في الهيئات الدوليه
سيتم ملاحقه هؤلاء الناس في الوقت الحاضر
وهذا يعترف به الاسرائيليون المحكمه
الاسرائيليه هي التي تشكل القبه الحديديه
فوق رؤوس المجرمين في اسرائيل
المتحده هي القبه الحديديه الدوليه التي
تحمي المجرمين في اسرائيل وبالتالي اذا ما
يعني
ذهبت الحمايه الامريكيه وتم تقويض صلاحيات
المحكمه العليا ستكون اسرائيل كما يمشي
عاريا وعندما تمشي اسرائيل عاريه تتعرض كل
القوى الاسرائيليه التي قامت بجرائم حرب
الى المحاكمات الدوليه هذا ايضا لا يعكس
فقط على الجيش وانما ين ايضا على علاقات
اسرائيل الدوليه وعلى الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي
وعلى المستثمرين الاجانب الذين يستثمرون
في الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي وهذه القوه
التكنولوجيه التي تترجح بها اسرائيل بدون
استثمارات اجنبيه لن تساوي شيئا فيهرب
المستثمرون سيهرب العلماء ويعودوا الى
بلادهم وبالتالي كل ما بنته هذه الهيبه
الدوليه
برعايه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه سيذهب
وايضا انطلاقا من الخلافات الواضحه ما بين
اداره الرئيس بايدن وحكومه نتنياهو هل
يمكن ان تكون الان الولايات المتحده تراقب
ولا اريد ان اقول بانها مرتاحه ولكن يعني
هي ربما تشعر بغبطه لانها حذرت نتنياهو من
ان هذا المسار سيؤدي بالضروره الى ما يحصل
الان
صحيح انه غال
بيه ما هم يهود البراليون وبالتالي يدعمون
الحزب الديمقراطي ولكن هناك في الحزب
الجمهوري تنافس الهدوه الديمقراطي في
امريكا وتدعم اليمين الفاشي في اسرائيل ان
كان من خلال منتدى الشرق الاوسط او مركز
ابحاث منتدى الشرق الاوسط في الولايات
المتحده في واشنطن وان كان من
خلال الموجود في اسرائيل وهو الذي
عدى كل هذه الخطه لليمين الفاشحه حتى
ينقلب على النظام القضائي
هناك علاقه بين
الصراعنه قوى الليبراليه بين القوى
اليمنيه الفاشيه
اذا مشيه في اسرائيل ولقيت دعما من الحزب
الجمهوري
وبطبيعه الحال سينعكس على الحياه السياسيه
الامريكيه ويهود امريكا
من العزله السياسيه لاسرائيل ومن انتصار
الحزب الجمهوري في امريكا لذلك يهود
امريكا يدعمون معارض الحاليه في الميدان
ماديا وسياسيا واعلاميا ويهود في اوروبا
ايضا قلقون جدا من انكسار النظام الفرشي
في اسرائيل عليهم في اوروبا لابد انك
تستمع لاجوبه السيد مردخاي كدار التي تعبر
عن وجهه نظر ممتعده ربما من التصرف
الامريكي مع اداره وحكومه بنيامين يهو
تواصل مباشر حصل بين بايدن ونيتانياهو ما
فحوى هذه الاتصالات وما مقترحات واشنطن
لحل الازمه الداخليه في اسرائيل
لا اعتقد ان الامر متروك لواسطه لتوفر او
لتقدم ايه مقترحات فواشن تريد حل هذه
القضيه من خلال السبل الديمقراطيه حيث
ينظر الى الحكومه وكانها تستجيب لرغبات
شعبها الذي انتخب الحكومه لكنني اقول هذا
من جهه من جهه اخرى من الانصاف ان نقول ان
اداره بايدن وحكومه نتنياهو تمر بعلاقه
متوتره هم ليسوا اصدقاء
الامور بينهم على ما يرام لكن في نفس
الوقت العلاقات بين الولايات المتحده
واسرائيل على المؤسس على المستوى
المؤسساتي علاقات قويه ومن شانه ان يتجاوز
المطبات الحاليه لو ان الوقت المتحده رات
ان اسرائيل تتغير بشكل من عميق ومبدئي مما
يتطلب اعاده النظر في العلاقات نحن ما
زلنا بعيدين تماما عن تلك النقطه الان
الولايات المتحده عبرت عن بواعث قلقها وهي
سترى كيف ستستجيب والحكومه الاسرائيليه
لرغبات شعبها الذي واضح انه قلق ازاء هذه
التعديلات القضائيه سيد صباغ قلت قبل قليل
بانه لولا المتحده الامريكيه والمظله التي
تؤمنها لاسرائيل لتم تسليم قادتها للمحاكم
الدوليه جونكوربي واضح بانه قال ان تل
ابيب لم تعالج القلق الامريكي من
التعديلات القضائيه ردا على تعليق هذه
التعديلات الى الدوره المقبله من الكنيست
اين يمكن ان تضغط الولايات المتحده على
حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو لو سمحت
او اجلت لفتره بسيطه هذه التعديلات
القانونيه ولم تلغيها ولم توقف هذا المسار
اعتمدته القانونيه جاهزه مرت كل المراحل
المطلوبه وضعت الان على طاوله رئيس
الكنيست يعرضها للتصويت بدعم او لا
متحده في الوقت الحاضر لها مصلحه ان يتم
تسويه
الخلافات والصراع في اسرائيل لان كما قال
بايزن يريد اسرائيل قويه واسرائيل منقسمه
على نفسها ليست قويه واي مواجهه عسكريه مع
الخرج في حين ان الجيش منقما على نفسه
والجمهور منقسم منقسم على نفسه لم تكون
اسرائيل قويه اذا مصلحه ان تكون هناك تف
اهمات كيف يمكن ان تضغط المتحده ربما
تستطيع ان تظهر على جمهورها الليبرالي بان
يقبل في حلول وسط بين
فريق نتنياهو فريق جانس وربما يكون جانس
اكثر قربه من الحلول الوسط ولكن اعتقد انه
النتن وان بنك
مستعدون لحلول وسط
جوهريه وانما مستعدين لحلول
تعديلات بسيطه في المقترح ولكن ليس جوهريه
طيب والسيطره
وهذا ما سيفعلونه انه بعد انتهاء فرصه
الاعيان سيعودون ويعرضون
المشاريع القوانين الجديده على على
الكنيست الاسرائيلي بعد عيد الفصح طيب
الى اين تتجه العلاقه مما الات العلاقه
بين نتانياهو والبيت الابيض على ضوء هذه
الاختلافات الكبيره
الواضحه في الملفات الداخليه الاسرائيليه
هذا ليس
شخصيا والولايات المتحده الولايات المتحده
واسرائيل
لهما الاكاد على الاف من المستويات
والمشاريع والموضوع والمواضيع وهناك اشوف
ميني هناك شيء عشر حالات لتاريخ كل يوم
لامريكا يعني لمدن مختلفه في امريكا
بسبب الرجال الاعمال وائل والعلاقات
العائليه هناك الاف الخيوط التي تربط بين
الولايات المتحده واسرائيل هذا ليس بين
نتنياهو والبيت الابيض فقط ولذلك السؤال
يعني السيارات السؤال غير صحيحه العلاقات
بين اسرائيل وامريكا متينه سميكه
ثابته
منذ سنين عديده وهي الابد ولذلك هذا ليس
شيء عن متروك لنتنياهو او لهذا الشخص او
لاخر
سريعا بيجي كراولي هل ستتاثر العلاقات بين
اسرائيل والولايات المتحده الامريكيه جراء
هذه الازمه
نعم انا اعتقد ان العلاقه هي قويه لكننا
نعتقد ايضا انه المتحده لم تتردد في
الاستمرار في الاعراب عن باعث قلقها اذا
ما احدثت اسرائيل تغيرا كبيرا جوهريا في
هيكليه نظام حكمها شكرا لكم السفير بيجي
كراولي في واشنطن مردخاي كدار في تل ابيب
واليب صباغ في الجليل
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر شكرا لكم على حسن المتابعه الى
اللقاء بامان الله ورعايته
[موسيقى]